you're so good in this movie so
unexpected which i loved
um you played such a nice guy for years
on the x-files so what was it like for
you getting to channel your inner dark
side with this movie
well when i read the script um
you know a lot of things uh changed
towards the end right so i was reading
the script and i thought well this is a
very interesting script and it's very
very very good for present day and i
like what it was saying and i like that
it was a kind of a
horror film too yeah and then and then
uh
and then i kind of got into this idea um
actually um you know you're from canada
right there was a guy named
uh jordan peterson up in the university
of toronto and i was reading
the script i was thinking wow this be a
this would be a fun kind of uh
this is like jordan peterson like if he
was in a horror movie in a way
and i thought that'd be an interesting
thing to try to try to bring
you know these guys that do these these
kind of men's movements and and
you know men's rights which is kind of
oxymoronical right so
i thought wow that's it's an interesting
kind of a vibe to try to get at
well it you nailed it it was really good
you freaked me out
and what was it about this script that
you really liked in terms of you know
the fact that this movie's coming out in
2020 you said you kind of liked kind of
this spin on
on the craft yeah well that was really
what uh drew me to the project was uh
zoe lister jones had written this script
and i i didn't know zoe um but um
as i read the script i thought oh this
is all
kind of kind of a perfect reboot or
or re-envisioning of a classic idea
you know and i thought you know what we
were
what we're going through a year and a
half ago
and and in what we're going through now
um
all kind of part of the same piece which
is kind of a
you know a bit of a rebellion a
rebellion against a
an existing power structure you know i
thought wow to tell that within
within kind of a fun frame of a horror
film was really cool
also with a sense of humor yeah well
people cannot get enough of you and
jillian anderson you guys are working on
a charity
together so i want to know how that all
came about because you're raffling off a
30-minute zoom call right
yeah i say yes to stuff i don't even
understand what i'm saying yes to
i couldn't tell you any more details
about it i mean julian uh
got in touch with me and asked me if i'd
do that and i said sure
so have you gotten used to the zoom call
format like are you used to all of this
yet
uh no uh if you would have been here
like five minutes earlier you would have
seen my son
uh copy and pasting which is something i
can't even do stuff like this
uh i'm i'm at a total loss
when i come to this so absolutely not
but i i have been able to
zoom without any incident so far so uh
wish me luck
okay good luck that's i've been doing it
for about six months and
there tends to be tech issues sometimes
so you're doing good you're doing good
um so i want to know whenever you get on
a new set
do people instantly want to geek out
with you about the x-files like do
people ever come up to you just to say i
want to believe and then run away
uh no they'll they'll come they'll
they'll talk about ice files in
californication or
or other movies that i've done even
aquarius sometimes so
no not really i mean you know certainly
there are fans
um and fans that have been there for a
long time but
but uh you know when you're on a set
it's mostly they want to talk about
what you're doing right now you know
yeah that's awesome well uh you were
very fun and scary to watch in this
uh so yeah i can't wait for everyone to
see it thanks so much for your time
i appreciate it thank you
you